a Nintendo guitar and hey you it's
episode 16 of IMG hey Mario
what's better than a 1-up Oh but what
powerup causes this the same artist also
gave his spin to Pikachu a smurf and
Bambi we all know this is from Star Wars
but have you ever seen it bolded and
aligned into art and here's an exhaust
pipe in the wrong place this is what
happens when pac-man drops off the mail
and this is what happens when Batman's
sit poolside if that girls are more your
style sit back and enjoy BuzzFeed's
treasury of girls wearing Batman stuff
cute pose wait what nine eyes tumblr
calm is one of the best locations for
scenes caught as Google's street cameras
drive by there's no context or
explanation so all you can do is wonder
what how and in some cases who last week
people were saying that I showed too
many cats an IMG well not to worry there
will be no cats in this episode except
for these fifty reindeer cats
and this cat who's learned the art of
camouflage you don't see him until it's
too late if you're looking for the
opposite of cute checkout BuzzFeed's
rundown of the craziest hip hop album
covers also scary these actual edible
cakes we've got a human skull of poop
cake for a guy named Dan a baby baked
into a cake and guts the only thing more
unfortunate are these tombstones rape
weed buy and of course dumb fart
prospective illusions have always been
my favorite and this artist makes some
of the largest he paints on entire
buildings and sometimes more than one
building they look disorganized at first
but from the right angle everything
aligns and the seam looks flat they're
100% real and it check out more of his
work follow the link in the description
where links to everything in this
episode can be found oh nice a cookbook
mm-hmm natural harvest a collection of
see yep and here's a rose made to cast
an even more beautiful shadow the same
artist also used violins keys and more
via reddit we've got a microwave get it
a micro way and this one was all over
the place last week including
facebook.com slash Vsauce gaming take a
look at Facebook's front page connect
the dots and wow you guys submitted some
other cool stuff on our Facebook page
like Blake who showed us reality worst
game ever with this trolli addendum
no wonder he's using Windows I'll leave
you today with some anachronistic
Photoshop so be sure to check out screen
team shows giveaway video for a chance
to win some awesome prizes including a
WoW loot card that I give away in a
cameo in the video click here to watch
it and as always thanks for watching
you